we've got a first look at the box start
for new Xbox games stadia is getting sec
euro and some new exclusives and sip 6
is adding Ethiopia next week I'm
chastity and you've reached your safe
set for Tuesday July 14 so last week I
showed you what the PS 5 game boxes look
like and they're very similar to the ps4
and this week I've got even more
breaking box art news for you this time
for the series X and I'm sorry to say
the Box R for the new Xbox games looks a
bit messy we've seen what a PS 5 game
box looks like thanks to spider-man
Miles Morales and now we know what a
game box looks like for Series X thanks
to dirt 5 it's definitely a less clean
design thanks to a big sticker that says
optimized for Xbox Series X combine that
with a list of enhancements at the top
HDR support and smart delivery for
example and it becomes even more
cluttered the word 1 is removed from the
border of the box of the top just says
Xbox again because Microsoft is pushing
for one eco system across its consoles
Microsoft has made it a point to support
new games on both Xbox one and Series X
so this label clarifies that a game will
play on both or it's trying to there's
so much going on that my eyes aren't
sure where to look anyway Xbox Series X
is coming this holiday and so is that
big sticker and shout out to everyone on
Twitter calling for that sticker to be
even bigger like this redesign from
Steve Kim this double sticker treatment
from blank field 5 and this watchdogs
Legion concept box art from hardcore
metal 89 keep them coming y'all send me
your concept box art on Twitter at
chasity underscore V I wish I was
optimized for Series X if you missed the
new stadium X the big takeaway is that
it's getting secured oh and some new
exclusives
GameSpot's 2019 game of the year sakura
shadows die twice is coming to stadia
this fall more games were announced for
stadia including WWE 2k battlegrounds on
September 18th
hitman 1 & 2 also in September hitman
three when that launches in January 2021
and outriders this holiday check out the
full list of announced games from the
latest stadia connect on GameSpot and
there are also 5 exclusives being
developed for sadya Splash Damage known
for brink and Gears tactics is making
out casters competitive multiplayer
shooter in a distinctly stylized vinyl
world robot entertainment known for
Heroes Academy and orcs must
I will release Orcs Must Die 3 as a
stadia exclusive harmonics uppercut
games and supermassive games are all
developing stadia exclusives to
civilization 6 is getting a DLC pack
next week adding a theo pia and a new
game mode the next DLC is called the
Ethiopia pack and it arrives on July
23rd on PC and consoles
it adds Ethiopia as a new civilization
with its own leader plus new buildings
and a new district the pack also
includes a new game mode called secret
societies it adds secret societies to
the game world and if you discover one
you unlock an extra powerful secret
governor whose bonuses can be assigned
to any city the Ethiopia pack can be
purchased Alucard for $5 but it's also
included in the game's new frontier pass
the pass includes six ELC packs and
Ethiopia is the second the third pack is
launching in September just a reminder
that we're still raising money for
charity with the GameSpot Store head
over to store documents on to buy cool
play for all merch for yourself or a
friend
including face masks t-shirts hoodies
and this awesome skateboard all proceeds
go to charity until the end of August so
head to the store get something cool and
help us raise money for a good cause and
that's your safe safe for Tuesday I'm
chastity and you can find me on twitter
at chess
kurt will be back tomorrow with more
news I'll see you next time
[Music]
you